avec karin viard nommé cette année aux
césar pour une chanson douce seule
nomination pour le film d'ailleurs c'est
un petit peu dommage mais tu représentes
toute l'équipe ce soir présente le film
vous étiez là l'année dernière vous avez
eu le césar du meilleur second rôle pour
les chatouille ou d'andrea bescond vous
avez eu treize nominations je prends au
total depuis le début de votre carrière
est ce qu'on s'habitue
c'est pas mal mais mme karin viard mais
pas karin viard c'est la classe est ce
qu'on s'est habitué à ce type de
distinction de la profession est-ce
qu'on s'habitue
non je suis pas très stressé parce que
j'ai l'habitude mais on s'habitue pas
pour autant fait toujours autant plaisir
wouah moi ça me fait vraiment plaisir
karine c'est un contexte très
particulier cette année dans quel état
d'esprit tu es juste simplement d'être
présente aux césar c'est important pour
toi sans entrer dans le détail
je me pose pas la question c'est une
question de respect c'est moi voilà
c'est la ligne que je me suis fait je me
suis donné c'est bien de rappeler que
c'est la fête du cinéma moi ça reste une
fête ça reste boat célébrer le cinéma
aussi et d'encourager le cinéma est
d'encourager la création française
oui oui tout disait non mais oui oui bah
moi c'est une cérémonie à laquelle je
vais si j'y suis convié évidemment oui
voilà intéressant si j'ai bien servi
j'ai été plus brillante à d'autres
moments
merci car il a toujours brillante on
vous aime karin viard merci beaucoup